[Music]
what's up everybody this is marion from
geek culture here with you for another
fantastic geek unboxing
and this time we have the one the only
cyberpunk 2077 collectors edition
so yeah you might have heard of this
game for quite some time i mean it's
been around since 2013.
but we're here today
it's finally here yay yeah so
here we are to unbox
finally the collector's edition of
cyberpunk 2077 and
let's get to it shall we
okay so bring this box front and center
as you can see the sleeve is all decked
out in that nice yellow
neon yellow kind of coloring that we've
constantly seen in all the trailers
posters and whatnot
yep as you can see there's v here main
character of the game that's you and me
and v
and forget that uh yeah uh yep let me
just turn it around as you can see
so this is basically the outer section
of the collector's edition let me just
turn it over to the side here so you can
if you notice
kind of if you look closely you can kind
of see the outlines of
like a building so
in a sense uh they kind of
uh
they kind of designed this uh cover to
resemble that of a building in night
city which is pretty cool i think like a
skyscraper so to speak
but yeah
let's just
open up this little section here so you
can see a little bit more of what's
inside
and here we go
okay
so as you can see there's a little bit
more of the building-like structure on
the outer design here so let me just
turn it around once more
[Music]
and as you can see it kind of looks like
an apartment
one of the apartments in night city
and yeah once you play the game you'll
kind of understand what why it looks
like this but it there's no spoilers or
anything here it's just
really cool design so yeah so before we
get to the nitty-gritty of things there
are actually a couple of things that
come at the top of the box so
first item here is
you can see this this is a patch set
of the various gangs of cyberpunk 2077
so there are seven main gangs
and their details are in here
i'm gonna let you just pause the video
so you can just take a look but yeah
so there's seven different gangs and the
final patch over here is the cd projekt
red logo
pretty cool huh all right so i'll just
leave this to the side
and then
we have the game so this is the ps4
version of cyberpunk 2077 and this is
the main box that'll uh the main retail
box it will come with
and yeah
let me just open it up a little bit for
you so we kind of
slid it open just to see what's inside
so this is the game this is the cover
this is the game
yep very nice
ps4 box standard kind of standard
looking but it's pretty cool
then it also comes with a set of three
postcards one for different locations
you can send it to your family friends
relatives loved ones
you know
yup you can write your stuff here stamps
and all that cool there's also a map of
night city
and voila
so this is the main this is night city
in its entirety this is the main
location of where you'll be playing the
game
as you can see there are six districts
each of which
they look pretty distinct from one
another and yeah you can put it up in
your room as like a poster
if you wanna like flex to your friends
and whatever
and finally there's a world compendium
which gives you a brief
look at
night city itself
yeah
so with that out of the way here's what
you get in the game case itself so you
have two disks a data disk for
installation as well as the game disk to
boot up and play the game
you also have a sticker pack
as well as instructions on how to
download some additional digital content
for the game
we'll tell you what the contents of
those are
as well as a welcome note to night city
so the coolest thing about this game
case is that it comes with a reversible
cover so when you take it out you
actually have male v on one side and
female v on the other side pretty cool
huh
so yeah this box kind of looks like an
apartment of sorts in night city even at
the top they didn't waste any
space in design so you can see here
there are vents or like air conditioners
and stuff like that
typical things that you would see at the
top of an apartment building in the city
there's also like uh car park like
looking things or maybe uh kind of look
like helipads i'm not really sure but
yeah
just little little things that add up uh
that give this
this box alone a lot of character which
is cool
all right so now we're done with that
let's get into the main unboxing shall
we
all right so with that out of the way
let's get to the piece the resistance
everything else
so
back to this beautiful beautiful box as
you can see this is all just an outer
sleeve
if i to take my hand and just lift it
like this
voila you're everything else so yes this
is the same design
the previous cover that you've seen
all that
nice
awesome looking aesthetic of their
apartment design
and now
let's
remove this top lid for you
all right here we go
so as you can see i'm a little bit too
short for this so forgive me if you
can't see my face but
here we go so
there are two main compartments here let
me just tilt this
over so you can kind of get a look
so yeah
it's crowning
so yeah um let's get this out of the way
first i believe this is
the
please stand by
let's get this away this is the box
for i believe it will be the art book
pin stick patches and all the other
little trinkets
alright so beautiful
cardboard box here
that has the cyberpunk logo
yep all decked out in yellow and black
again
with a nice little handle at the top
as you can see
all right so let me just open this up
so
oh wow
pretty huh
i like this okay
so what we have here is a bunch of cool
cool stuff so
um while i'll get to this i'll get to
this in a bit let's take a let's take a
closer look here so
this little portion here is i believe
actually my favorite part my personal
favorite part of this collector's
edition because this
is essentially a printed out plug
of everyone at cd projekt red that
worked on cyberpunk 2077 how awesome is
that
so yeah you kind of have a little piece
of everyone at cg project red
to bring along with you if you buy the
collector's edition so that is a really
nice touch here so it's a nice little
nod to all the hard work all the blood
sweat and tears they kind of put on uh
especially during this crazy pandemic
period and obviously over the past
almost 10 years that they've been
working on this game
so it's nice to kind of
see all their efforts
essentially immortalized in this little
space here so yeah
good job cd projekt red
with that out of the way here is
uh basically almost everything else in
the collector's edition so what we have
the big boy over here this is the art
book of cyberpunk 2077 really nice
hardcover book
really nice smooth kind of almost felt
like uh casing
yeah this kind of serves as a really
nice uh coffee table book if you want to
like spend your
your your weekend mornings just just
reading uh i mean with a coffee or tea
by the side yeah so if you take a look
uh kind of flip through it you
will essentially
get a glimpse of everything
in night city from all the different
districts
uh the denizens gangs
important npcs
johnny silverhand
so on and so forth vehicles monsters
and cybernetic upgrades so yes pretty
detailed stuff if you want to learn more
about the law of cyberpunk 2077 this art
book is one of the best
things that you can get from the
collector's edition
all right so let me just put that to the
side
and yes we have
the steelbook case so you can actually
place your game discs
from the regular game case over
and store it here or you want to just
put this up for display
it's really pretty as well cyberpunk
2077 logo right here
look it's just really really
nicely done very nice uh production
quality here
awesome stuff
and look this little plasticky thing
this is a guide to night city which is
encased uh very nicely thematically in a
nice little evidence case
so as you can see it's been
authorized by a
by the essentially the night city police
department or the ncpd for short the
detective that commissioned this was
uh
detective riverward he's one of the npcs
in the game you'll meet him
shortly i shall not mention any more
spoilers other than that but yeah
so if i to open this
it's basically
a
all right
so
really nice packaging uh probably don't
want to throw this because yeah it's
cool looking
so yeah this little booklet is another
guide to night city
it shows you all the different
aspects of night city in a small
gazetteer like
style so
you can kind of read it from the pov of
one of the people who live here
really really cool
make your nice city dream come true
really nice lettering and all that
awesome stuff
and yes
and you know just to kind of
role play a little bit let me just put
this back in the evidence case because
you don't want to you know get it dirty
you know
okay so there's four little
box thingies here
what are they right so first one
this
is a keychain
that features one of the cars in night
city
really pretty yeah you can yeah i mean
you can put your keys on it that's why
it's called a keychain
next one is
another patch set
so
uh slightly bigger patches from the ones
that we've seen earlier
a closer look at what these things look
like
so the samurai logo patch
i believe this is
the ncpd
and just a regular night city logo patch
so if you're a biker
like zacky
yeah you can put this on your jacket
awesome stuff
so this is a sticker pack another
sticker pack featuring all the different
corporations
of night city so aside from the various
gangs there are also mega corporations
in night city these are the guys that
essentially
uh run the city
because they have cash and power yeah
you can kind of shameless plug all right
there's there's other uh stickers for
um
different brands uh
in night city obviously obviously
they're all fictional
but they have a really they have a lot
of character put a really nice spin on
things and again really nice to put on
your laptop your your bike helmet or
whatnot
yeah
so lots lots and lots and lots of
stickers
that you
can decorate your stuff with
we have
some label pins so
yep nice city heat i believe that's a
sports team correct me if i'm wrong on
this leave leave it in the comments
below
and there's also
the pin for militech militech is another
mega corporation this these are the guys
that essentially develop the weapons
for the denizens of night city and
beyond so this little section here where
all the signatures are at
you can actually put your steelbook case
here if you want to safe keep them for
some reason
uh yeah so it's another nice way to kind
of store your game your game case or you
can even store the regular game case
here so yeah if you want to just display
this section
you can absolutely do that as well so
that's really really fun really nice so
that is all we have for the
this box here the actual actual piece
the resistance
is right here
all right
a styrofoam box
[Music]
with cyberpunk logo on it
there you have it guys don't forget to
i'm just kidding so anyway
this is
the
statue
of
let me just show you
all right and here we go
[Music]
beautiful so what we have
base plate
let's get this out
made of a really strong
i'm gonna say resin material but again
correct me in the comments down below
really really pretty so yeah this is
just a roadside
um
yup really nice detailing here oh my god
you have to see a little nice bag here
strewn clothes and
takeout boxes
and yup cup of uh like i'm gonna call it
coffee or cola
soda and then there's a yup there's a
blaster here a pistol and obviously the
cyberpunk 2077 logo and of course sorry
there's another little groove here where
we're gonna slot in
a v
all right i think this is the bike okay
but yeah
okay slot it down there
okay so
this is
the second part of the
set piece this is
this one consists of
the bike that v rides on smashing
against or rather impaling
a are crashing into
a corp i want i'm gonna say a
corporal
hitman
really nice detailing again uh look at
the little chrome like painting or paint
job over here
um
yup tons of decals on the side
even if you take it if you can look
closer at the
yup at a little fella
okay if you take a closer look at the
the corporal guy here um there's a nice
bit of
uh yup he's very nice expression really
well painted lots of detail
um yeah you're gonna hear a lot of
detailed detail later because this thing
is detailed
uh 2a t
really really nice oh yeah you don't
don't try it trying to remove the wheels
because they don't move
and what you're going to do is this
little groove here you're going to slot
it down here
on this side so it kind of looks like he
is
getting
smashed onto the ground like this that's
gonna hurt that's gonna hurt
and finally
lynchpin is
v himself
so as the game's main protagonist
looking all
badass like he should
yep and this is made of like a like a
rubber material very different from the
res the solid resin material here um
kind of providing quite a nice bit of
contrast
even his uh
his rifles uh
sling is also made of a rubbery material
which is really cool and yes really
angry looking v here with his dual
pistols
and yeah
so this
yeah as you can see on his sneakers
there's a on the underside of one of his
shoes there is a
pin here that you need to slot into
so if you can see on the bike there is a
little
hole down here which you will insert
these foot into
alright
so it kind of looks like this
[Music]
okay
so you might want to apply some glue
just in case but
but regardless this is a really really
beautiful piece
as you can see
really intricately detailed
yep
so this is basically v multitasking is
killing off one enemy while he's already
making his way to gun down another and
that is the essence of cyberpunk 2077
guys no i'm just kidding so yeah
um
obviously this is the centerpiece of the
collector's edition
the yeah this is a really beautiful um
rendition of v in action and
it kind of shows
um the essence of the game
and i think it kind of makes me want to
play a little bit more what do you think
zeki
alright that's the way so before we
forget this statue measures about 25
centimeters or 10 inches
speaking of which
you're gonna love this game
[Music]
and so we've come to the end of the
unboxing of the cyberpunk 2077
collector's edition and just for
information this
beast of a box
retails for the price of around 250 us
dollars
or 389 singapore dollars and for what
you're paying
you're getting a literal treasure trove
of goodies from the cyberpunk universe
that you can deck out your clothes
and your room
and your dog and your fridge
you get the drift but yeah so it's a
really beautiful beautiful package and
we have to say this is one of the most
comprehensive collectors editions
possibly in all of gaming so far you
never know we'll see
but
yeah kudos to cd projekt red and
everybody else that contributed to the
making of this collector's edition so
we've come to the end of our video we do
hope you enjoyed it and if you did maybe
give us a thumbs up and if you haven't
already maybe click the subscribe button
down below and maybe smash that bell
icon for more geeky updates tidbits and
more unboxings like this one also if you
yourself are getting the collector's
edition or more importantly are playing
cyberpunk 2077
maybe drop us a comment below to let us
know your thoughts and with that in mind
this is marion from geek culture signing
out
right how's my line
hey
dude i was just reading from the script
it says in the script no but still ah
who's mine man
[Music]
you